minecraft freunde minecraft freunde dazu
bist es klappt das
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zur christmas kraft zur ersten folge
hier auf dem kanal von ghom und mir ich
weiß jeder hat in seinem dienstag gesagt
dass denen auch dabei sein wird
allerdings komme sagt warum er nicht
dabei ist weil er bei den media kreft
wintercamp dabei ist und sich
entschuldigt ist automatische papagena
wetter dazu stoßen in den kommenden
folgen noch oder vierten in der vierten
oder gewitter dazu kommt weil wir werden
das so machen dass die erste folge erst
auf allen drei kanälen ist außerhalb der
dena der ist am schlafen oder irgendwie
recht einfach den aufnahmetermin
verschlafen
der weitere opel händler haben er
bereitet sich auf dem winterschlaf
er hat einfach um 17 oder 18 100 einfach
geschlafen also keine ahnung was bei
denen los ist
wir wollen das so machen dass die erste
folge einig bei den augen und mir kommt
deswegen kommt jetzt nur bei ghom und
wird die zweite folge kommt auf meinem
kanal die dritte bombe und die vierte
kommt dann bei den das wird er wohl
schaffen die fünfte kommt er wieder bei
mir die sexbombe blender bleibt also
entweder kuranyi eine playlist oder
abonniert alle einfach alle kanäle für
die weihnachtszeit wir haben es noch
keine weihnachts kostüme und so nicht so
viele gedanken darüber gemacht nur
gedacht dass wir immer kommentare nehmen
von euch wo ihr uns themen schreiben
könnte über die wir reden sollen zum
beispiel oder größtes missgeschick zu
weihnachten oder größtes geschenk das
ihr euren eltern ihr gekauft habt euer
bestes weihnachten das ich hatte
irgendwie sowas ich hunger schon kanns
mir ein bisschen es ja wirklich oder ich
auf hatte am aluminium
heute wird geteilt werden der erst
anwender muss geteilt landsleute wir
haben im übrigen war texture pack drin
das wollte ich erwähnen das wunderschöne
richtig dass die super schön aus und ich
habe mir schon bei dir richtig gut
eine schöne weihnachtsmütze vorstellen
bei dem skin der deswegen sollen wir das
weihnachtsgefühl machen
dann schreibt einfach mal die kommentare
weil ich finde dass personen mit den
weihnachtskonzerten minecraft hat den
erfolg inventar bist du heftig über
kunden gebraucht bis ich erstmal gut so
wir dachten jetzt einfach dass wir hier
so ein bisschen wir wollen jetzt hier
nichts großes mehr pvp mäßiges machen
natürlich auch pvp es immer mit dabei
erkennt er von epic job
doch welche via tod wird jetzt einfach
die friedlich uns irgendwo hin bauen
haben super bio herausgesucht
wir wollen wir ein paar schöne dinge
bauen die mine wegen beispiel einen baum
oder so oder ob er ist einfach so
weihnachtliche dinge hält kinder und
bildet es ist total war übrigens komme
wo bist du gehabt die schulter verloren
und steht daher du bist ja ich komme
hier sieht sogar eine wette
hier kann man super geld sich hin bauen
und dass die nada nach den haushalt ich
habe ein haus komme hatten haus oder
bomben weihnachtsmann oder sowas hier
könnt ihr zb ja wir bauen auf dem
verschweigen und geschick und für holz
ist das hier auf jeden fall ein bisschen
beruf aber nach vorne war richtiger wir
müssen erstmal holzholen spitzhacke
machen wir höhlen touren und reden dabei
weihnachtliche dinge ganz genau dass bis
weihnachten
genauso wie es weiter an bis zum 24
läuft das hier dann auch dass ihre bis
dahin am start zeit die es geht die
sonne geht gerade unter fünf minuten auf
das wetter wieder dunkel anke may kreft
danke soweit ich mache dich mach es beim
crafting kevin wollen natürlich auch
gemacht als teilen hier in dem projekt
weil weihnachtszeit ist natürlich auch
die weihnachtszeit wo man dann auf teilt
ich wollte schon steine wir werden auch
ich weiß nicht ob er am anfang an
zusammen wohnen werden oder und den
wienberg rahmen werden aber 24 folgen
sollte man schon schaffen dann irgendwie
ein eigenes rennen zu bekommen uns was
alles also wird knapp glaube ich also
ich bin nicht gerade der große hausbauer
aber ich gebe mir hier natürlich
besonders mühe gerade auch ist anders
hier ja ich meine mit darf dann überlege
ich mir da mal wieder vor vielleicht was
ich bauen möchte oder was ich sonst auch
vor habe ich meine gerade die geschenke
kürbis haben nämlich die form von ihm
geschenkt glaube ich ja ja ja der
strecke verdanken
an der sag mal wie zwar nicht gemacht ja
wir erhalten jetzt einfach mal gedacht
das erste thema wurde mir bei twitter
geschrieben von us lp oder irgend sowas
er meinte wir sollten unser schönstes
weihnachten bisher beschreiben also erst
mal ich fange jetzt mal einfach ganz
dreist hier an krücken feiern heraus bei
mir ist es so ich fand die weihnachten
früher viel viel schöner als die die
heutzutage sind weil heutzutage einfach
diese magie irgendwie weg dass man sie
nicht mehr so wird man den
weihnachtsmann glaubt weil natürlich es
gibt den weihnachtsmann oder gar es gibt
natürlich immer natürlich man natürlich
gibt es den damals hab ich noch viel
viel kräftiger daran geglaubt und hatte
halter noch wünsche wieder irgendwie ja
das playmobil auto und das stofftier und
sowas und dann hat sich das ganze
entwickelt dann eben zum zum gameboy und
dann soll mitspielen und hat man sich
auch noch mega doll gefreut
jetzt ist es mittlerweile so ich weiß
ich bin irgendwie komplett glücklich mit
meinem leben und das einzige was wir
wünschen würde zu weihnachten jetzt
dieses jahr zum beispiel die playstation
4 aber dass wir denen nicht klappen weil
die gar nicht mehr irgendwie zu ich habe
eine höhle gefunden ja aber ich habe die
jungs hatten zombie gefunden wie kann
man ihn ja nicht kaufen oder sollte als
in reisen wir brauchen jetzt fackeln
dafür braucht aber kohle das doof wochen
unter schock sag mal hast du dich auf
hardcore gestellt oder was ist los man
hier kommt immer wieder neues monster
weil hier zwei ci slot kann uns hier
erst mal auf halter dies plustek links
gucken wie die aussehen komme er ist
geil oder auch wenn der baum vielleicht
mal wächst kann es sein dass der
vielleicht dann auch so ein mega geil
weihnachtsbaum mengen wäre glaube ich
wir können für testen könnte man testen
wir schauen einfach mal
wir können ja eventuell hier sogar
bleibe oder hier doch eine schöne gegend
tirol ja wir haben halt hier noch bäume
und sehr schnell gehen
ja man könnte hier hatte ich fand die
ecke da hinten auch eigentlich ganz geil
da wo ich schlage laufen einfach mal vor
jetzt mal auf das thema zurückzukommen
ich gebe dir da auf jeden fall rechne
ich denke das ist es hängt mit dem alter
auch zusammen ja das ist bei jeder weiß
ist genau aber ich geb dir da völlig
recht dass es früher mal an den meisten
leuten wirklich viel schöner noch vor
kam weil man damals halt noch vielleicht
einmal wünsche hatte noch ein
weihnachtsmann geglaubt hat natürlich
gibt
doch die ganzen anderen fahrers mein
ding wenn jemand etwas böses gesagt hat
nein gesagt hast du gehört man dann
könnte man sagen ich rufe jetzt den
weihnachtsmann an mein lieber milchbubi
ja ich rufe den bekommst du eine rosa
hallo ja hier der milchbubi da hat
wieder war heute böse der hatte gesagt
ich bin blöd man das soll einfach mal
keine geschenke bekommen so albers ich
hoffe weihnachtsmahl also irgendwie hier
finde ich kann man kann man super
rodelbahnen machen wäre theoretisch ist
ein gebäude machen für seine
schlittschuhbahn macht nur noch eine
hochhaus 4 hat das ist klasse hier sind
wenn so ein weg und jeder so eine brücke
irgendwie und über ihre scheine auf die
hockete wenn wir jede folge zehn stunden
lang machen dann klappt das
wir schaffen das du kommst du übrigens
nicht mehr auf wenngleich es komme
absolut los los los
das skelett hatte weihnachten zu auf die
zombies auch mal okay okay okay wir
wollen zusammenarbeiten
wir haben wollte ich meine wir brauchen
erstmal fackeln oder wollen uns hier
erst mal wie könnte theoretisch offen
sieht geil aus hast du schon mal
reingeguckt matte es um kabul hat sich
ab dass wir uns hier so ein halbes haus
packen können ich könnte auch einfach
eine schaufel machen aber nein
ich brauche schon mal so die
körperumrisse pause sollte hier bauen
oder wo was dann die grund umrisse von
einem haus mit x naja kann zumachen
sollen ja auch ein bisschen erde noch
geben oder oder wie wir etwas
abschlusspech holz ok ich nicht
vielleicht erstmal eine axt dafür aber
gottes jetzt meine eltern zugeworfen
bist du der holzfäller der holzmichel
bist normal liebt ist richtig nichtmal
ehrwürdiger minecraft spieler im feld
einfach vom baum nur ein stück abgeht
dann zum nächsten baum
und was war was war so bisher also dein
schönstes weihnachten weil darüber mir
noch reich gerät er mit über die
entwicklung von weihnachten gerettet
mein schönstes möchtest du jetzt ein
jahr haben oder was mein schönstes
beschrieben
wir sind so erstmal die kirche gegangen
haben uns da so diesen gottesdienst
angehört und ging nach hause gegangen
nach dem krippenspiel und gottesdienste
und hier ist ein super mit einer
wintermütze geil
doch ich glaube dass man schwert auf
jeden fall sind wir dann nach hause und
da war der weihnachtsmann in seinem
kostüm der da hatte sich in einer
verkleidet aus der familie
ich glaube das war mein opa letztlich
als ja das war dann das war einfach ein
highlight natürlich für mich ich hab den
weihnachtsmann gesehen hat dann auch
noch fest so richtig fest daran geglaubt
habe und so und dennoch schön geschenke
da hatte ich dann auch noch etwas cooles
bekommen oder doch schön essen irgendwie
keine ahnung aber das ist mega
besonderes neben diesem
weihnachtsmannkostüm kenne ich da auch
jetzt nicht war hatte ich nicht
also bei mir war es halt auch immer so
dass wir alle immer es möglich war und
ich fand die kirche nichts gegen die
kirche aber ich fand damals als kind
echt richtig langweilig im einfach so
zwei stunden der kirche zu sitzen
es war zwar schön mit krippenspiel und
musik und sägen und mit verwandten und
freunden darum zu sitzen
dann möchten die geschenke entfleuchte
einfach die geschenke sehen und dass man
hat halt das sind halt quasi so die die
normwerte von kindern halt wenn man
weihnachten denkt denkt man an geschenk
und nicht an teilen und weihnachten und
freude dem was in unserem haus wo
herzlichkeit also der pass auf muss aus
nein nein bestimmt bald verdammt aber
ich kann es direkt wieder aufbauen ich
hab genug
jetzt kommt der zombie alter ich glaub
ich hab mich ein bisschen laufen heute
glaube ich ehrlich wo bist du denn
irgendwo du hast keine minimap hier drin
kraft hatte erfolg monsterjäger als
saubere berufen das tun dass man das
alles sieht ja also ich weiß nicht wann
für mich war weihnachten immer und ich
denke viele andere auch geschenke und ja
und mit freunden und so aber nie
irgendwie soja teil als coach mit einem
song geriet man die kommt von überall
gemalter freude bist du ich helfe dir
mal eben schnell und ich habe was
mitgebracht was aber etwas mitgebracht
geschenke geschenke geschenke soweit ich
mach uns mal an den rand ihrer schon
wieder nur von überall kommen die erste
schwierigkeit gespielt aber okay wir
sind ja jetzt mal an den rand so tolle
sachen hier hast du schon schwer tja ich
hab dir sogar ich wollte sogar ins geben
hier
ok dann paul hier kannst du dran oder so
an spacken bist du aber das ist wirklich
irgendwie schön dass wir so oft komplett
vanilla spielen finde ich irgendwie weil
hexe das immer so ja noch den
medaillenspiegel oder nehmen wir da eine
rüstung mit der besprühung verstärkung
haben und das ist sein spiel wechseln
das ist hier das ist einfach vanilla das
ist einfach so wird sie gar keine
fensterreihen machen gruppe noch nicht
erst mal hier eine bude wo wir sicher
sind keine fenster oder hast du schon
sand habe ich nicht ich habe meine ruhe
haben wir da unten
aber wir haben auch sand wo haben wir
sind da überall guck mal hier links von
hier haben wir einen kleinen mini strand
ehrlich ja also ich hab kein holz mehr
das heißt ich kann daraus nicht weiter
aus schaut euch waren die gommel hausbau
guckt ihr guckt immer die tür angekommen
bitte nicht spitze ist ein langsam an
das ist aber krempelte haus machen
warte einfach so erfolgreich weil es
sieht wunderschön aus auf jeden fall
schreibt mal übergangen ändern
ich bin halt einfach so der beste
architekt auf der welt aber ich kann ja
manch außerdem offen schmeißen dann
kriegen wir vielleicht kohle verstehst
du stehe ich natürlich das sind so die
alten vanilla tricks ja genau damals war
so colo colo kann man aus wie jupiter
herstellen so mega projekt sechs
diamanten
wir werden uns richtig hier werden wir
richtig viel spaß haben
wir brauchen übrigens eine rüstung aber
wollen wir schon die erste höhlentour
angehen aber wir wollen das erste
höhenwind wochen erstmal fackeln und was
braucht man noch hören
aber dafür brauchen wir können wohl
nicht mehr schaffe schaffe ich auf jeden
fall drei wolle frei hast du schon ein
wettkönig mir machen
okay ich hab hier schon mal zwei ich hab
drei schafe sehr ruhig und cool einmal
wettmachen und muss fortsetzen
für den er hole ich vielleicht aus
meinem bett ja genau wie können wir den
auch schon mal was holen den asylanten
nach rest dazu stößt aber wir kämpfen
uns ja alles da kommt dazu direkt alle
sache
machen sich hier vor dem jugend er macht
sich erstmal in you can also eine luft
das finde ich würde das feiern
ich hab hier nochmal wollen irgendwie
bekommen überall bäume hin damit
eventuell nachher noch hierholzer die
setzlinge sind einfach nur megageil man
natürlich auch richtig schwimmen
ich brauche schon mal hier im bettchen
ich mache mir schon meine tür
also ich muss echt sagen wir sind jetzt
bei 15 minuten die erste folge ist schon
vorbei ich möchte eigentlich direkt
weiter spiel und jetzt in die erste
hürde gehen
ich möchte auch gerade weiterspielen
können eine etwas längere geht das nicht
wir können etwas längere folge machen
ich mein mann kommt die heute so 17 18
uhr so drehen weil wir können noch mal
fünf minuten hier um pilger
nimmst du das liegt nach vorne dann
schneide ich dich da kurz raus aus der
fans kämpft
du musst das irgendwie daraus den ja
hier ja ich schneide ich da raus du
kommst hier nicht rein
ja die ganze asylbewerber hier ist
einfach nur ihre eine wollen alle
einfach nur das projekt hier rein da
halt immer haben sie an als würde ich
mein ganzes team auseinander lage der
ist sarah meinem leben einfach das war
der weihnachtsmarkt soll ich jetzt
einfach mal schon mal holzer und
reinpacken bei uns in mit dem spruch
'wenn wir machen können
soll ich das machen können wir machen
kann ich mir die höhenzüge dass deswegen
wir wie mache ich das überhaupt muss ich
bloß wird und reinpacken oder das andere
andersrum okay dann haben schon mal zehn
kohle das sind 40 fackeln
obwohl aus holzkohle kann man glaube ich
keine fackeln machen
doch doch okay wichtig war dass wir beim
album hin macht das aber haben wir ein
wunder höhle ich hier schon mal schauen
ob wir hier irgendwo der höhle von ich
habe schon der höhle gefunden ehrlich
wurde die schau dann lieber auch normal
wahrscheinlicher hier im wald
wahrscheinlich hier schneit es schneit
welche für die erste folge und rosen
die schönen roten rosen nämlich allemal
mit doch hier ist eine hülle direkt bei
unserem haus hier
das ist keine höhle es ist wieder seiner
unterschlupf nein auch noch eine höhle
ich hab schon mal bei ich schenk dir
heute was 20 fackeln habe ich schon
richtig nett willst du jetzt mal mit
hier unten eine höhle ist reinhold gall
wo das ist keine höhle quatsch auf das
eine höhle ist hier der spitzhacke doch
habe ich okay glück wieso kann ich das
so langsam abbauen
das ist eine wurden mit der wir müssen
am besten ganz eisen kohle erst mal
mitnehmen das sicher drin liegen wert
war lässt alles liegen aber hier hätte
ich schon wieder mit der höhle schluss
hier ist ganz ehrlich
dann ist es seine ressourcenhülle dann
immer einfach die paar sachen die wir
haben auf jeden fall die kohle ist
wichtig weil da haben haben wir trotz
der höhen tour für die folge heute schon
mal ganz gut
hier kommt wirklich gar nichts ich hier
nochmal ein bisschen durch die grammatik
also nur hier ist lava sie endlich
einmal shoppen nein wir dass es ein
weihnachts projekte da müssen wir
zusammenhalten
findest du wer
schildau dörge okay ich hab die kohle
was du bist ja alles so gefallen
erweisen gefahren vier stücke wie ihr
ganze stücke als zunächst ich habe ein
eisen was kann man daraus machen
wir können zwar reisen schwerter machen
oder sollte man lieber eine spitzhacke
machen ja cool besteht dunkel hier drin
ach du bist so witzig nicht richtig
witzig aber ich hab ne menge kohle hier
okay leute sowas kann man mit kommen
einfach nicht spielen so ich gehe raus
lasst mich erst jetzt komplett zugebaut
willst du alter ich liebe dich ich werde
ich irgendwann liegen verlassen so die
holzkohle ist auch schon mal fertig
jetzt jetzt kommt der moment der
wahrheit wo wir empfinden heraus finden
der auch eva klein kann man daraus
machen sie also nicht einfach es ist ein
haus das wieder ruhe ein
es war ein schlag ich bitte dich
das war ein schlagbaum ich hasse dich
lieber gott ich wünsche zu weihnachten
weihnachten eine bessere rüstung und ich
wünsche mir dass man mich nicht immer
schlägt und wünsche mir ein besseres
könnte dafür locate nach hause wollen
meine sachen dann machen wir hier schon
mal das ende der ersten folge klar ich
komme zu dir du bist echt du weißt du
ich blende immer nur so von wegen
sogleich schlag den jetzt ein bisschen
skelettmuskel atkins klettern kabarett
wo blau
ich komme von der seite wo ich die ganze
zeit ins wasser geschubst habe das
glaube ich auch jetzt erstmal hier das
dach fertig ich finde mein bett ist
schon völlig vorher zugeschneit das ist
natürlich tacke wieder zu hause gleich
mit der zeit kommt man hier die
produktiv ich plötzlich bin kaum müsste
mal tot
ich hab ein herz sein
doch mit einem schlag ja ich hatte ja
auch noch irgendwie passiert mit meinen
sachen von craft ist das schiff mit etwa
hardware fackeln jedoch ran und dann
kriegst du deine sache noch schnell
wieder hier ein bisschen fleisch dann
eisen schaufel die stars ananas meine
fackeln keine fackeln sich den klubs
soll solche kuscheln macht beides so
mehr habe ich aber auch schon gar nicht
mehr
ja okay gut das passt auch kohl habe ich
noch gehabt colo colo colo
da haben wir warten erstmal ab wir haben
schon die dann hätte ich mache mit
meinem bett kannst mir einen holz geben
ebenholz natürlich hier bitte danke
schön bitte brigitte danke franke okay
da steht nämlich schlaf hier nicht
schlagen ich habe ein herz das meldet
kommen darf auf meinen wert ist auf
jeden fall gemütlich mit blumen damit
ich mit roten rosen schenken letztlich
den weg laufen dann würde ich sagen
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst auf jeden fall eine bewertung da
und schreibt die kommentare themen über
die wir reden sollte und soll muss ein
weihnachts kind machen für die nächste
folge und schreibt alle unter den aus
videos dass er sich jetzt endlich mal
bei uns melden sollte das ist das
allerwichtigste
und dann würde ich sagen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen und die letzten worte
gibt jetzt komme ja ich meine die tür
hier die müsst ihr euch noch einmal
reinziehen
wie geil einfach mal die türe
ausgeguckten die man hier die sind schön
für schmuck an hammer garrigues schöner
erster advent erstmal genau haben wir es
noch nicht gesagt ich wahrscheinlich
also noch mal fröhlichen erst an wenn
euch alle da draußen und an seiner
stelle auch haut rein bis zum nächsten
video ich freue mich selber schon mega
auf das projekt hier und auf die
kommenden folgen
und ich werde auch die rega witzig und
sei jetzt was wollt ihr denn für
geschenke haben ich bin der
weihnachtsmann